We played
a game of
ping pong
battleships!
where the goal is
to pop
all of your opponents
balloons
but you can't see
where they've placed them
First ones to lose
all their battleships
have to jump
off a battleship...
All right
let's start building
our battleship setups!
And each player has three
special battleships
marked in a different color
and if you pop one
you get a hidden note
that gives you an advantage
or a disadvantage...
Okay, Emil you ready?
Yeah, I'm ready
WOOOOOOO!
No worries
I still have eight left!
Sorry Miikka!
I saw from your face!
That it was really close!
Oh, it was a complete
poker face Emil!
I'll just aim there
the same place!
No luck!
I'm still waiting for my first pop!
That was a blue one
What's the special rule Otto?
Miikka...
Sink your own battleship!
Noooo!
Everybody likes that!
except Miikka
I got to think
which one I'll sacrifice
I think I'll just pop this one
because it's the most
annoying one
Ah now i hit it!
If it hits the balloon
and it doesn't
pop for some reason
then you still get the point
*pop*
What's my special?
Defend your battleships!
Defend my battleships!!
There you go
The rule is
I can
defend the next two shots
with this
magical weapon!
You're not coming over here!
Okay, my turn!
My defenses are up!
*battle sounds*
Goodbye balloon!
There we go
Why do I feel like I'm
100%
gonna end up in the ocean
after this...
I agree
I heard a bounce!
Another special one
I'm getting all the special ones!
Shuffle!
Move one balloon!
That's good
Okay guys, I'm ready
Boom!
Oo, it almost came back!
That was a special one
Okay, let's see what your
love letter says Emil...
Oh, how about that?
This one's for you guys!
Remember to hit subscribe
That's a nice love letter
Emil, you got lucky this time
It's not sacrifice your balloon
Exactly
Good try! Good try!
It was really close Otto!
Thank you
I'll remember that next time
Yeah
Very nice!
Nice
You got to remember where you've hit
Oh, again
So close!
Aaah!
Now he took it away!
So
there's one ball there
Don't pop it!
Yes!
you're welcome Otto!
Thank you
Special rule!
message says...
Minimize!
Make one ball smaller
That's probably the best one
So half size
Maybe this one
again
So close Otto!
Yeah I know
That's really the spot
you wanna go for
I'm not going to reveal anything
just gonna look you
directly in the eyes!
Maybe I'll just
try to go for a jackpot!
At least I hit the table
I didn't hit the same spot anymore
Changing tactics
did good for you!
Yeah, was it a special?
It's a special
I hope he get's something terrible
What is it? What is it?
No, he got the air strike
Whoa!
Okay, unleash the air strike
I will!
Miikka's turn
Think it was close?
That was very close
Okay then I'll
try to aim for that
Yeah
you hit it!
Good advice!
Good teamwork!
I saw from Otto's eyes
that he like, blinked
Ah, okay okay
the eyes are exposing things here!
The fishing net thing...
There!
Was that a special?
It's not a special
I saw from your eyes!
I keep exposing myself
There is another one, like
very close to the one
where I hit
I'm going to get my sunglasses...
It's come to this
they're looking at my eyes
all the time
You're like a poker player!
This guy!
Can you see where
I'm looking now Emil?
no
Yeah...
He was bluffing Otto
Yeah
Says the guy with the sunglasses!
Emil, it was...
Special?
Nice!
Reveal one ball
It's here
We know where to go!
Emil gets
the mega ball!
Here it is
the mega bouncy ball
I'll go for Otto!
Well, at least
two good bounces!
That was the ball you revealed?
Yeah
Good shotto!
Now I'm going to get that one
that's over there
No, It's the special!
No...
Donate! give one ball away
We all know you're
not getting it Emil!
Miikka
Can I get the one ball?
Time to say goodbye to my
strongest battleships
I think he's
going to make it to the end
No, you can't put it bouncing on!
put a back side spin
That's not allowed!
That's just cheating
That was a hit!
That was a hit
I feel like I've hit that
same place as well
many times
but it's not there...
I'm so happy for you Otto!
Feels like it's two versus one!
We got to get you
out the game!
Clean hit...
I'm out
I'm going to get dumped
into the ocean...
but now I can see
where you've put your balloons!
Don't even come close!
At least put your sunglasses on
That was very close Otto
Thanks to Miikka
I at least have the one left
Exactly!
I'm technically
still in the game
Oh, so it's your balloon?
Who will join me?
That was clean
It's so exciting!
I've covered everything...
You got it!
And where was it?
No!
What!?
Miikka, we get to jump
off a battleship!
Going to be great!
Yeah
Okay Miikka
you look like you're ready to
do some swimming
One, two, three
Go!
Guys
remember to hit subscribe!
See the subscribe button here
Don't go!